(upbeat music)
- I'm gonna get that.
This is the one I wanted.
- [Narrator] Mike Shinoda
co-founded the band, Linkin Park,
one of the bestselling
acts of the 21st century.
♪ One thing I don't know why ♪
♪ It doesn't even matter
how hard you try ♪
- All my first beats were
sampled off of vinyl records.
- [Narrator] Lately, he's sold a lot
of vinyl records and he likes to buy them.
- Dude.
(Mike chuckling)
Now that's what I call rock.
- [Narrator] He's not alone.
Vinyl albums outsold CDs last year
for the first time since 1987,
to the tune of $1.2 billion.
In today's digital era,
people can hear hundreds
of millions of songs anywhere,
and yet vinyl, expensive,
immobile and left for dead is booming.
(record player whirring)
(upbeat music)
- It was kind of like, well,
yeah, that's never coming back.
I was wrong.
- I didn't foresee it.
- No physical formats ever
came back until this one did.
(record player turning)
(record player whirring)
- [Narrator] Here's why this
antique format is coming back,
both in spite of
and because of the
digital music revolution.
- In the beginning of the beginning,
around the very early
part of the 20th century,
there were wax cylinders
that carried sound recording.
- [Narrator] Thomas Edison's phonograph
introduced recorded music to the masses.
Eventually, it used discs like this.
(indistinct happy singing)
- These little black pellets
are ultimately melted down
and it becomes a biscuit that
gets pressed into a record.
- [Narrator] Mark Michaels is the CEO
and owner of the largest press in America,
United Record Pressing in Nashville.
- Back in the '60s and '70s when vinyl
was really the only
format that was relevant
and it was the core existence of United.
It was a very, very busy place.
- [Narrator] But the
format had its limitations.
- And you couldn't really listen to it
on the way to work or while
you were doing anything else.
And so CDs were far more convenient.
- [Narrator] In 1987,
CDs outsold vinyl records
for the first time.
- We almost exclusively
listened to CDs at the time,
and vinyl, we thought of it
as like that was an old people's thing.
- [Narrator] The format
hit its lowest point
in 2006 as iPods helped
digital music take over.
- When I bought the company in 2007,
it was a much smaller business.
We were 38 employees at the time.
- [Narrator] Music lovers
had nearly unlimited options.
Vinyl seemed dead.
- Nobody thought vinyl
was gonna come back,
except for the hardest of the hardcore.
- [Narrator] But in the
early 2010s, it did.
- We could ask the question,
why did that happen?
All of the music that has ever
been recorded is available
to almost all of us on our phones.
- There was something
missing in that experience.
- The album isn't just about the music.
- The answer lies in the
way we express fandom.
- I think a lot of fans see buying things
from their favorite artists as
keeping those artists going.
- [Narrator] Meanwhile, United
watched demand skyrocket.
- We grew to 90 to 100 people.
We went from running one and
a half shifts to three shifts.
We did everything we could
to accommodate the growth.
- It cost about the
same as a black t-shirt
at a concert and less than a hoodie.
And it contains the actual
music and beautiful graphics
and photography and
lyrics and other stuff.
And so for many fans,
especially young ones,
they consider that to
be a pretty good trade.
- [Narrator] Linkin Park's 2023 reissue
of their album "Meteora"
sold more than three times
as many vinyl copies as the
2020 reissue of "Hybrid Theory."
- The CD sales of "Hybrid
Theory" 20th anniversary
were around 13,000-ish.
The vinyl was around 3,000ish,
and by the time we got to
"Meteora" two years later,
it flip flopped.
To jump from one format so
heavily weighted to the other
in a couple years' time
is pretty substantial.
- [Narrator] And those
substantial vinyl sales
are helping the artists' bottom lines.
- On-demand streaming services
like Spotify and Apple Music
and Amazon and and so on
are paying out something
well under a penny a stream.
Artists are making significantly more
on a per unit basis from record sales.
And it stands to reason, right?
I mean, today a vinyl record
is gonna cost somewhere
between 25 and $30 per disk
- [Narrator] And many fans
prefer the sound of vinyl.
(record playing static)
(lively music)
- There's more life to it.
It draws me in.
I don't get tired of it.
I wanna listen to it more.
(upbeat music)
- If I got a record at like a garage sale
or something and it's an
actually, it's an old record
with dust and scratches
and it's got that sound,
then to me, it's a really
different experience.
- [Narrator] While vinyl is rebounding,
revenue from physical
formats made up just 11%
of recorded revenue in 2022.
(upbeat music)
Vinyl's continued growth isn't guaranteed
because records are
really hard to manufacture
and most machines are basically antiques.
- These are some of our
legacy Lenard presses.
Again, 50 to 60 years old
and one of the challenges
with these presses is,
you know, they break.
- [Narrator] And that can create a backlog
for artists and labels.
- Linkin Park is not
like a fair comparison
because the label does
prioritize our projects.
Our wait time to get the
vinyl done was six months.
So I have to imagine
for a lot of other
artists, it's a lot slower.
- It's very, very difficult
for an independent artist
or for an independent label
to schedule the manufacturing
and release of a relatively small run
of vinyl with great precision.
- [Narrator] But the
industry is catching up.
New equipment is finally being produced.
Mark just had 26 new presses
delivered from Sweden.
- Over the last two years,
we've been putting this together.
It's an $11 million project
- [Narrator] Now United
presses 60,000 records a day
and has 234 employees.
Despite the challenges,
some industry professionals
think the format is here to stay.
- As long as there is demand
for a bespoke analog way
for a consumer to connect to an artist,
vinyl will continue to be a significant
and growing part of the business.
(lively music)
- I don't know that it'll stick,
it'll beat CDs or beat
other formats forever.
But for now, at least people know
that when they're buying an
album they love on vinyl,
like they're buying it for a reason.
It's a keepsake. It's a collectible.
That's more of the mentality.
(upbeat music)